blew 42 hut-hut I'm angry we all know
that the best sport is football it's got
everything our country stands for
violence and not listening to scientists
but the NFL has been taken over by beta
male snowflakes these guys have never
met a patriotic song they didn't want to
attack with kneeling luckily though
football has a savior Wrestling
entrepreneur and 80s haircut
Vince McMahon you might know McMahon as
the genius behind the XFL as you know
the XFL was a football league that was
so awesome they ended it after a single
season in 2001 what the players lacked
in skill they made up for in jerseys
that said stuff like he hate me on the
back and there are rumblings that
McMahon is bringing the league back he
just sold 100 million dollars of WWE
stock to fund a new venture which will
reportedly include pro football I for
one and pumped and so are my Canaries in
the mine over at Breitbart they know
we're hungry for a football league that
caters to real Americans who love
football but are sick of the social
justice warriors in the NFL they even
have a name idea for it Mogga FL the
make America great again Football League
this story is too exciting to cover by
myself so I want to bring on all of my
football buddies Tim bolts Tim you mind
if I taught you this story to get your
thoughts want to play wide receiver to
my quarterback I don't understand your
analogy Jordan okay
but I am fired up for the mag of
football league this is the greatest
thing to ever happen to me
other than the time I made a chicken
parmesan using only beef right Tim do
you have any inside information on how
this league will run yes and not yes
Jordan McMahon hasn't offered any
details but Breitbart has supplied some
directions for how the league could
thrive for example they said the league
should embrace traditional American
values place franchises in cities with
high populations of Trump supporters and
make players stand for the anthem
I agree in fact they should play the
anthem so slow that it lasts the entire
game and there's no way to kneel during
booth also I have another suggestion
make the entire stadium into a locker
room so fans can finally let loose and
be themselves I was at a Philadelphia
Eagles game the other week and it was
like drinking tea with the Queen only
five people told me to eat my own ass
brilliant in Philly I know but those big
sexy ideas are just the beginning Jordan
I've been fantasizing about a megaphone
believe in my basement for years next we
will get rid of the safety right because
no defensive backs will make for a
faster quicker game no there will be no
safety period I mean Trump said earlier
this year that because of the new
concussion regulations the players so it
hit hard enough so in the Mogga el
players will charge up the gridiron in a
lawless melee of destruction maybe
they'll have big sticks and torches who
knows but I estimate that only 1% of
players will reach the end zone Dov
brilliant so only the top 1% get to
succeed know that that's America yes yes
it is Jordan there's gonna be so much
winning in this league people are going
to be sick of winning yeah that was
great today no literally Jordan fans
will grow sick of it every team will go
undefeated
the Washington Redskins the Cincinnati
red skins the Pittsburgh Redskins logo
so Tim so every team in this league will
be named the Redskins no of course not
there will also be the Toledo savages
the st. Louis legal slaves the godless
ok yeah that's ok you know I yeah I get
the picture it's clear well best of all
while real Americans league is
flourishing the NFL will be turning into
an ultimate frisbee game at the Rhode
Island School of Design
while the NFL is kneeling to kumbaya
mega FL mascots will be real uncaged
lions while the NFL is doing trust Falls
and concussion exams the Mogga a fell
t-shirt cannons will be replaced with
actual cannons and while the NFL is
raising awareness for breast cancer
the Miguel will be raising awareness of
breasts and hey where's my picture of
breasts no Ted we're not we're not we're
not doing that I sent you like I said I
don't six to choose from Oh Tim no we're
not technically I sent well it's not
gonna happen to him Jordan each of those
paintings took me a very long time yes
Tim Tim bald steak thank you for coming
on oh I almost forgot another team named
the Seattle Redskins yes Tim bolts
everybody the opposition will return
[Music]